Twitter under the leadership or lack
thereof of Elon Musk is now labeling
NPR's account as state-affiliated media
this is quite literally untrue NPR
National Public Radio is not State
Affiliated media we're aware of
different places that do have
state-affiliated media and when that's
the case it's appropriate for them to be
labeled as such but NPR is completely
independent of the US Government Federal
money in general is a part of the public
media ecosystem NPR receives under one
percent of its budget from federal
sources and most importantly it is not
at all affiliated operationally with the
federal government the latest very
pathetic attack on public media